des fois on parta à l'attaque alors
boulette il donit ordre à mes petits
c'est l'heure il faut y
aller qu'est-ce qu'il dit baonnette mais
qu'est-ce qu'il dit tu comprends toi ce
qu'il dit baonnette ah baonnette au
canon articule B articu je vous fer tous
fusiller est
méchant alors vite on fix nos
fourchettes CC clic tout cont ch on va
sortir
boufflette il grimpa à l'échelle on se
poussait du coude les gars vise un peu
la grenouille il va faire
beau il posait le pied sur le parapet il
sortait son petit sabre court fait
surmesure exprès pour lui au creuseau il
désignait la TR unchnemi etigé En avant
en avant et vite il s'écarté pour n Il s
passé